speaking of which yeah home game for uh
will kane and
we're also talking home for congressman
dan crenshaw uh gop congress making real
impact
congressman i get two things number one
people were quick to jump down your
governor's throat when he
lifted the mass mandate 18 other states
have looked to the mass mandate
and i sensed there was a degree of glee
when you guys got hit with that freeze
and your infrastructure was unprepared
for it did you pick up both those things
i did look people are jealous of freedom
and
and one of the unfortunate realities of
modern america is we're sort of dividing
into
you know free states versus non-free
states and um as you just indicated on
your show
and people are moving with their feet
they want to be free right they
now a lot of people are enticed by the
democrats you know
notions and sort of lip service to
compassionate arguments
but in the end they want to pursue their
happiness as the declaration of
independence
gives us the right to so look you would
have thought that texas made masks
illegal
based on the unhinged response from so
many leftists on twitter
talking about murderers and killers and
look you you're siding with the virus no
more vaccines for texas is what they
said
this is really disgusting i mean it's
disgusting on a very fundamental level
look
i think you should still wear a mask if
you can't socially distance and you're
not vaccinated
but i don't want to find or jail you if
you don't
right this isn't that hard of a concept
guys you know there has to be a contract
between
between the the governed and the
government and there has to be trust
involved and what we've lost over the
last year
especially because our public health
officials have not been totally honest
with us
um our government officials have made
emotional decisions instead of logical
ones
and that trust has been broken lockdowns
don't work
they don't work that's why that's why i
introduced the end lockdowns now act
because it's based on a premise that the
science
says there is no correlation between
slowing the spread
and shelter in place orders locking down
businesses it doesn't work it's a virus
it spreads it's unfortunate
but it does and i think democrats need
to listen to the science
listen to the data and actually absorb
that information
and stop hurting people well lockdowns
don't work
except at the southern border and they
seem to work during the trump years
but now with joe biden you know there is
this gigantic surge they won't call it a
you know they call
it a challenge but congressman i think
you know the messaging from the white
house right now is
don't come now i think they want him to
come now
because uh it's messy but
ultimately it's going to get things
going so that they can get to what they
want which
is as people in your party say open
borders
yeah look i'm i'm done trying to read
their intentions any other way
um it's very very concerning every step
that the democrats take whether in
legislation or in this administration
is meant to have more illegal
immigration so we want completely
different things here
and this is a very sharp left turn for
the democrat party
over the last 10 years it's very
unfortunate look there is a crisis on
the border now
now biden may not actually like that
right they might want a more steady
uh even-handed flow over the next few
years but there's a crisis
thousands of people i was just down
there last weekend our border patrol is
overwhelmed
and the fact that they're overwhelmed
processing people being bus drivers
being daycare workers
guess who has to foot the bill for this
texans since we're on the topic of texas
texas dps spends hundreds of millions of
dollars a year
trying to secure our border because
while border patrol has taken off the
line they can't patrol the border
anymore
because they have to deal with hundreds
and hundreds of people bringing their
kids across
the river well then texas dps extract
has to actually patrol the river
they have to get in helicopters and
patrol there they have to go after drug
smugglers
uh they have 600 pursuits in just in
just one area
over the over the course of last year
these are really dangerous times for
them
so i actually just introduced a bill
that would pay taxes it's a bipartisan
bill by the way
that would pay taxes back for the
billions of dollars that we have spent
on border operations that are a federal
responsibility
oh wow what are the chances of getting
that money
that sounds fair it does sound fair you
know what we're already spending 1.9
trillion on a bunch of other nonsense i
think maybe adding some money to the
border
might be a good investment i want to ask
you something when you went down to the
border
i just can't fathom letting my child go
i know maybe they can they come from
dangerous situations alone
and so many unaccompanied kids what are
their stories how have you heard any of
those stories how are they
how are their parents allowing them to
do that i understand they know it's a
better life in america but
what what are you hearing yeah i mean
look it's heartbreaking and we have to
talk about the compassionate side of
this
it also demonstrates what an amazing
country this is that you can just tell
your
child your only child perhaps that if
you just walk across that border you're
probably gonna be okay because that
because our country is that good okay
megan merkel
it really is that good um and uh
and you know here's the thing they come
across they might have they might have a
cousin they might have an
uncle oftentimes they're just they might
have somebody that they that
they think will sponsor them a friend or
something on the other side
um but it's completely overwhelming um
to our border patrol like
this is completely unsustainable you
know when when trump was getting a a
a bunch of crap for the kids in cages
thing and now bine's doing the exact
same thing
look the lesson here is it's really
really hard to deal with thousands and
thousands of miners whether they're with
an adult or whether they're alone
all at once in fact it's near impossible
to do this well it's a completely
unsustainable situation
the reason this is happening is because
biden
completely reversed the trump
administration policies of remain in
mexico
and asylum cooperation agreements with
the northern triangle countries
these were our silver bullet right these
created a disincentive to come because
we said
look if you're gonna if you're gonna
claim asylum and only about 10 of people
meet this the legal standard for asylum
then then go to the local consulate go
to the local embassy
wait here in mexico we will adjudicate
your claim but you can't just come in
here get a bus ticket every
anywhere and then you know not show up
for your deportation hearing
when it's when it's shown that your
asylum claim you know isn't valid
that's unfair and you know who it's
unfair to legal immigrants for one
it's also unfair to millions of people
around the world who can't just walk
across the border
who have truly valid asylum claims we're
clogging up our system for people who
really need it and it's just not fair
it's not moral
and the thing is when you talk about
comprehensive
immigration reform it starts with border
security and you were getting it
and you had money for the wall it was
already it's already been spent and now
you're paying penalties not to build it
then you turn around and make it easier
maybe for these country
people to get here legally but you're
saying
that people from triangle countries are
more important than people from nigeria
from zambia from costa rica from norway
from around the world you're saying
they're more important so that's who
this
and brazil that's who this should be
about we can only
bring in so many people you could do it
legally or illegally
don't think you're going to come back
and talk to republicans
about immigration reform when you refuse
to enforce the border
we've seen this movie since 1985.
yeah no that's exactly right and we have
to foot the bill for it and look it's
reversible
this is a completely solvable problem
you have to actually
uh reinstate those those cooperation
agreements with with our partners which
is mexico honduras guatemala el salvador
they want to work with us there should
be somebody there now dan
there should be somebody there now
meeting with all these three countries
yeah exactly but the bite administration
doesn't want to look i mean
they their plan and they have a plan in
place they've already released it and it
does involve
giving illegal immigrants citizenship
and voting rights why because they want
them to vote for them i mean
that's a cynical you know proposition
but it's but i don't know how else to
interpret it i think it's true
speaking of voting later today the house
could actually vote on that uh
1.9 trillion dollar
covid relief bill and nancy pelosi
i've got news for you mr crenshaw she
can see
through what you republicans are trying
to do listen to the sound bite and then
we're going to get your opinion
i'm so excited i just can't hide it
all of it excellent all of it
fair all of it an opportunity for us to
grow the economy
by investing in the people for the
people for our recovering colleagues who
they say no to the vote and they show up
at the
ribbon cuttings or the presentation
so she says republicans are going to
vote no
when it when it counts but then you know
when when people come out and see the
folks at the ribbon cutting or the mall
opening you republicans are going to
take credit for all that dough
well you know the thing is is this money
isn't being invested in you
or your economy and look if you're
really happy about getting a fourteen
hundred hundred dollar
check you know again imagine that right
giving free money to people is popular i
get that
yeah but here's the thing it's costing
you five thousand seven hundred dollars
give or take and if you're not paying
for it your kids are
look if this is really as popular as the
democrats say it is we're in a lot of
trouble as a country it means that we've
we have fully given in to this notion
that we should be bribed by our
government for false promises
and that is not an american thing to do
we have to collectively stop doing that
it's going to destroy the next
generation it's already it's already
threatening to cause
massive inflation here's the other thing
about this bill
there's already trillions hundreds of
billions about a trillion dollars left
unspent from past relief bills okay
there is money in the ppp fund that
could go to small businesses
if you change the standards of how they
get it right that would be smart okay
um half of this money won't even be
spent until 2022
or later it is an absolute lie for them
to say that this is an emergency relief
bill
that goes and invests directly into
people it is for a lot of different
nonsense that has nothing to do with
cove but only nine percent of it
has to do with covet healthcare only
about one percent is for vaccine
distribution
these people are just lying and we can't
keep falling for it as americans
we cannot keep believing this falsehood
that that the size of your heart
is attached to dollar signs right and
whoever's willing to spend the most
money of your money by the way is
somehow more moral
this is simply not true i think that's
what a lot of people are upset with they
don't mind the nine percent they don't
even mind the checks that's wonderful
bless the lives of other people yeah but
it's all the extra
pork that's just thrown in there and
they can't do it because
everyone's getting a check we're
preserving native american languages
it's an emergency
everyone's forgetting them for 10
million dollars we'll remember them
fantastic and look we we fell for this
too as conservatives i remember in
december i remember a lot of people
wanting two thousand dollar checks but
look
it doesn't mean it's good policy there
there is no free money
yeah and and here's the thing that those
free checks are going to go to a
well over 100 million people who never
lost their job at all who've just been
working from home
so is this really what we need to be
doing is this really good policy no i
mean i don't think it is
all right dan crenshaw joining us today
from d.c dan thank you very much